6 41 on a wednesday morning
here it's time on good day las vegas for
our morning cup of joe with metro
sheriff joe lombardo who joins us live
sheriff good to see you once again this
morning
morning john go nights go go nights go
indeed
let's get right into a case that we've
been following for the better part of
two weeks here in southern nevada
there was an arrest made yesterday in
denver of samantha moreno rodriguez
she's accused of killing her son the
son's body found up near mountain
springs
the fbi was involved this case spans
from california to colorado
a lot of departments involved let's
first just talk about the coordination
to try and
get some resolution in this case
uh thank you john i i think first and
foremost our condolences
go out to the father of liam that passed
away
and his extended family and friends and
it's important for people to realize
that we care about that
and that we have some closure associated
with this case
but i brought with me anticipating this
question john i brought a list of uh
participating agencies and if you would
give me the
privilege of naming them because of
course
oh nice what a coordinated effort this
was so
the national center for missing and
exploited children clark county school
district clark county coroner's office
nevada department of transportation to
include nhp
night county sheriff and the school
district
border patrol san bernardino sheriff's
department child protective services
crime stoppers fbi california doj
san jose pd and denver rocky mountain
state streets task force um so
you had the question was the coordinated
effort yes i mean because you imagine
not knowing where the crime or the
kidnapping originally took place
it ends up in our jurisdiction unknown
where the suspect may be and across
numerous state lines it's important for
us to coordinate with all the other
associated law enforcement agencies that
can help us
in this endeavor
and sheriff i think you cut out a little
bit there but um if you're still with us
sheriff
uh there was such an effort to make sure
that we could identify
um the the uh the victim in this case
identify him i believe we may have lost
connection to the to the sheriff here
we'll continue to try and press forward
here there was such an effort made by
law enforcement to try and identify the
victim in this case
and as soon as that identification was
made uh
we were able to uh we're going to catch
up with the sheriff in a second i
will uh try and re-establish contact and
get to those questions oh we got him
back
it's technology it's how we do things
here sheriff i was asking about the
effort to try and identify the victim in
this case and how much of an effort was
by law enforcement to make that happen
once there was the identity made there
was an arrest made soon afterwards
how challenging was it for detectives to
get to that point where at least
the victim in this case the boy could be
identified and then move forward
yeah unfortunately you're fully aware
that there was a misidentification in
the early throes of this investigation
and
and that was a mother uh that believed
it was possibly her child and
and we don't have to get into the
details of that but unfortunately it was
a misidentification
but in the situation of a juvenile we
don't have a lot of data to work off of
you know dna
and other archived information that
people usually have
we have a database because of what they
go through during their lives or
previous arrests or anything of that
matter
so in a juvenile it's unique so
we knew hopefully with all our
media outpouring that we would be able
to identify
this young man via friends and or family
people wondering where the young man had
disappeared to haven't seen him for
quite a while
and subsequently we were able to do it
through that
method a friend of the father
became aware of the composite drawing
and asked the father some questions and
said it possibly could be
the father's child and through
investigation through san jose pd
in contact with the father we were able
to put two and two together
and and tracking someone down nationwide
like this you mentioned all the
different agencies that were involved
there's so much technology that's
available to pinpoint where someone is
that you're looking for
how might this have played a role in
finally able to
catch the mother in colorado uh you're
correct
i mean it played a significant role so
we have a suspect possible suspect
identified but we're trying to locate
them
they're going across new state lines and
the whereabouts is unknown so we have to
employ the use of technology
in this situation so that technology is
probably not a public
information piece that i want to provide
at this point
because we are still continuing the
investigation we have a suspect in
custody we want to ensure that they
have due process associated with this
case so it's important for us to
keep that compliment so at this point
you know one of the things that
lieutenant ray spencer from the homicide
unit mentioned
in one of his press conferences what was
the number of missing children
all across the country uh and and the
effort to try
and uh find them obviously is an ongoing
effort uh what kind of police work is
done
to try and help folks that are finding
missing children all the time
to track down those kids yeah that's a
big number
uh you know interesting enough and i
appreciate the question and in our
research during this uh
the ncic the national crime information
center which houses
when you report a child missing a report
is taken
that's placed in the national crime
information center
and as you can see the numbers on the
board 365 000 plus last year
was put in that system you know and then
those numbers come
in and out of the system as people are
located and and the cases are put to bed
because
people you know people are aware where
their loved ones are
or they remain in the system so that's a
big number and that's a big number for
investigative resources to try to put
their arms around
and investigate all those um particular
missing persons uh thoroughly
uh so it but it's a benefit for us when
we do identify
say a runaway uh down in you know
boulder highway area or anywhere in
in las vegas valley and we are able to
bounce um what information we are able
to obtain from the individual off that
database determine where they're
missing from how do we get them back to
where they
uh the parents who filed the report or
if loved ones filed a report
and subsequently returned them to where
they people are looking for them
well sheriff it's certainly an important
case we're going to continue to follow
it as i'm sure your detectives are as
well
and we appreciate your time this morning
here on good day las vegas
if you have a question for sheriff joe
lombardo here on morning cup of joe
submit it at eightnewsnow.com we'll
present it to the sheriff here on
television
and you can find out if your question is
answered every wednesday